you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
better late than never the much-delayed
environment bill which sets
binding targets to tackle climate change
is included in the queen's speech
we find out why six young people from
portugal are taking more than 30
countries to court
over climate change and growing
solutions how reforestation efforts are
paying off
around the world
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions and we aim to take you to the
heart of the climate crisis
explain the data driving the changes
that are already affecting us
but also show you just how far we've
come now the queen's speech today set
out the government's legislative agenda
for the year ahead and there was a clear
focus on climate issues
it included the long-delayed environment
bill which will set
legally binding environmental targets
and commitments
to restoring nature and biodiversity
the lifetime skills guarantee is
expected to give better access to
education and training
something welcomed by green business
groups who warned the transition to net
zero
could otherwise be hampered by skill
shortages in the future
but proposals for the planning system
could prove controversial if fast-track
developments don't fully consider
environmental impacts or promote green
building practices
well our science correspondent thomas
moore joins me now welcome to you thomas
and there's been a long wait for the
environment bill hasn't there but what's
in it
well it's the third queen speech can you
believe that has appeared in
work started back in july 2018 but it
has been so badly delayed
held over from the last parliamentary
session because the government said
there wasn't enough time to debate it
properly during the covid crisis
well what is it well it is the biggest
shakeup to green regulation in several
decades it sets out the environmental
protections
for the uk now that eu rules no longer
apply
the government says that it will improve
air pollution water quality
waste management the climate and
biodiversity
but green groups are concerned they
believe that it doesn't set
tough enough targets they're too
long-term to drive the immediate action
that is needed during this nature crisis
they also feel that the watchdog the
office for environmental protection in
the bill
lacks both independence and teeth now
all this is happening
during the year of the big climate
summit in glasgow of course when the
world's eyes are on the uk
and green groups fear that uh the
government will fail to take
enough environmental leadership in such
an important year
and that will be hugely embarrassing for
the country for it to stand the chance
of being passed in parliament
in time work needs to start next month
it is that urgent thomas thank you
let's take a look now at some of the
day's other climate news and the
government has announced 12 million
pounds in new funding to support
developing countries to better prepare
for and
respond to climate-related disasters
the fund will help deal with the effects
of extreme weather such as droughts and
floods
as well as predicting climate events
such as heat waves
[Applause]
ministerial departments are being urged
to use sustainable
laptops to reduce their carbon footprint
circular computing estimates emissions
would be cut by more than 196
000 tonnes over the next 14 years
if refurbished laptops were used instead
of new ones
the sustainable it firm says it would
also save the government almost 128
million pounds
[Applause]
trees are being used as pollution
barriers to protect people
exercising in london drinks company
tenzing has begun planting trees in
highly polluted areas of the city
popular amongst runners and cyclists the
areas have been identified using
tensing's clean air tracker and
pollution data
from imperial college london
[Applause]
most people in britain want single-use
coffee cup lids
banned immediately to reduce plastic
waste
a new survey has found 73 of adults
would support a ban on plastic lids
and nearly two-thirds say they'd pay
more for an eco-friendly alternative
two and a half billion takeaway coffee
cups are thrown away each year and only
one in
400 of those are recycled
and an artist has planted a ghost forest
in new york to raise awareness about
deforestation
myelin has created the art installation
using
49 dead cedars that were originally
grown in the pine barrens
an ecosystem on the atlantic coast maya
hopes the exhibit will show people the
devastating impact
climate change has on the natural world
now last year saw a record surge in
global renewable power according to the
international energy agency
it found the renewables industry grew at
its fastest pace since 1999
with the delivery of renewable energy
projects increasing by 45 percent
now by far the biggest increases were in
solar capacity
and wind turbines and you can see here
on our data dashboard
the real-time power mix in great britain
and we can see that 43
of electricity today is coming from
fossil fuels
we've got 38 there from renewable
sources
and 19 coming from nuclear and
that's actually a marked difference from
yesterday when we saw
60 percent of electricity coming from
renewable sources
now who is responsible for climate
change it's hard to pin down
individuals governments and businesses
all play a part in causing global
warming
and what can be done about it in the
future but for six young people
they think that countries aren't doing
enough to fight the climate crisis
and are taking them to court over it
following the 2017
wildfires in portugal the group took
their case of the european court of
human rights
arguing not enough is being done to keep
global temperatures below
1.5 degrees and now the charity saved
the children
has intervened in the case well here to
explain more is enrique scillias
director of policy and advocacy at
save the children welcome to you so why
you say the children
intervening in this case what do you
hope to achieve thanks anna
we are intervening mainly for two
reasons children
are by far the hardest hit by the
climate crisis they are
they are hit in so many ways on their
health on their education
on what they can eat and whatnot and
it's not just about
the children today but it's also that
the future of the generations to come
and we want to make sure that when the
court are ruling on this case they have
as much information as possible
on how the climate crisis are hitting
children
and their rights so that they can take
as an informed decision as possible
secondly and also importantly we are
really really inspired to see
children like the portuguese children
taking action
and and and to be part of decisions and
formulating how the climate crisis
should be
be taken forward so just the fact that
these children are there and they are
taking action with the court is
something that we think are worth
supporting and making sure that children
can be part of these discussions and and
and formulating decisions
many countries would argue we are
setting targets to reduce our emissions
we're laying out
our policies so what would your
counter-argument to them be
countries need to be more and do more
and they need to listen to children and
take action on what children
are saying they need in order to
mitigate the impacts
of the climate crisis so we hope that
by by by intervening in this case and
supporting this case
we have we have enough the court has an
opportunity to put a spotlight
on the impact of the climate crisis on
children
and their rights and hopefully also to
to to push government to accelerate
their their action in this area
and do you think litigation is the best
way to do that how effective
is the legal process enforcing
government policy change
of course litigation is just one part of
the solution right and and
one part of what we can do to push for
more action in this area
but we know from around the world that
litigation
can be a very effective way of putting
again as i said before
putting spotlight on the issues that
need to be addressed
and to push governments to do more and
to do better and it is crucial
that at this time and leading up to
cop26
in glasgow that we really make sure that
governments are there
looking at what needs to happen in order
for children and their futures to be
protected
ulrika sileus thanks very much indeed
now we often hear about deforestation
and the devastating
impact it has on our planet and while
huge areas of forest
are disappearing there is hope nearly
60 million hectares of natural forests
have grown
back since 2000. that's around 22
billion
trees and they have the potential to
store the equivalent
of 5.9 gigatons of
co2 more than the annual emissions of
the whole of the united states
and it's all due to different types of
reforestation happening
around the world well let's bring in
will baldwin cantelo who's director of
nature-based solutions at wwf welcome to
you
so i'm reading that you found that an
area the size of france has regrown
naturally in the last 20 years that
sounds pretty encouraging
it is encouraging and it's great news
it's good to demonstrate
the power of boris to be able to regrow
given the
the space to do so and and by doing this
we're providing
a great solution in the fight against
climate change
and what we need to do though now is is
to
to make sure that we can secure these
forests in the long term we can't take
them for granted and of course
deforestation is continuing at pace
around these forests
so it's important to secure these
forests for the long term
well yes and we're talking about natural
forest regeneration
how is that different from actively
planted forests
well in this study which is the first of
its kind conducted by
trillian trees we tried to distinguish
between
uh plantation forests and natural
forests which either grow
grown spontaneously all by themselves or
perhaps have had some assistance through
enrichment planting or otherwise and
what we've
by doing that we're able to talk about
the success
of efforts to
restore natural forests which provide
greater carbon benefits greater
biodiversity benefits
and actually achieve that unplanted
forests and of course they stole their
carbon in the long term
whereas plantations you have a
harvesting cycle that that you
harvest the wood and then uses them in
products if short-lived that carbon
then returns to the atmosphere will
baldwin cantelo thanks very much indeed
coming up on tomorrow's daily climate
show i'll be speaking to the climate
activist louisa neubauer who's one of
the main organizers
of the fridays for future school strike
in germany
you can catch that here on sky news at
the same time and on our social channels
and website
thanks for watching see you tomorrow
you